so what about these uppity do critical
race theory people did they learn about
segregation
or not that they're actually supporting
it these days
or actually i guess using communist
tactics
which brings me to our next story
check this out this is this is work it's
just real crazy man
daily mail reports cops investigate
virginia teachers facebook group
for naming parents who were against
critical race theory
and urging members to gather information
on them
they say the anti-racist parents of
luden county group shared personal
details of those they say had opposed
moves to teach the controversial
curriculum
i'm glad they're calling it
controversial it urged followers to
quote
gather information and silence critics
of the theory
others in the group encourage people to
share addresses and social media
according to purdue university critical
race theory scholarship
shows how racism can excuse me continues
to be persuasive
and why it denies individuals their
rights talk about
double speak on that one that's nuts but
critics say it leaves people exposed
to the training feeling that they're
being blamed for problems which they did
not cause
and that it itself is racially divisive
it's overtly
racially discriminatory and racist one
parent on the list
patty mender says i was personally
attacked lcps interim superintendent
scott ziegler said
we fully support the expression of first
amendment rights
and deplore any efforts to silence
voices
all right i got a question who who is
the lcps superintendent talking about
right there
he says we we we fully support the first
amendment and deplore efforts to silent
voices i'm guessing the teachers because
the liberals run all the school boards
so but wait wait
is he defending the people who are being
doxed because it was threatening to
silence them yeah or is he defending he
doubt right so he's defending the doxing
you're right
yeah man this is i would i would put
money on man
this is a cult yeah it's a cult ian dude
it's a cult it's
because we haven't we did have the civil
rights you're right
and a lot of people weren't privy to it
unfortunately but like united states has
never been a totalitarian dictatorship
so there's this threat of us falling
into it
seamlessly and man it looks like it
looks like that's what that's what this
is
it but listen it's social enforcement
this is the big thing it's from the
bottom up
that's where it gets really creepy and
then once people lose confidence in
government which is literally happening
i mean look at the six for instance
people are losing confidence in the
system
and then you get a bottom-up movement of
cultists who are just
the only thing they care about is being
in their cult
look these people were posting for years
anti-asian sentiments all over social
media
all over the place and then one day the
tide shifted and the cult decided that
was wrong now
and now they're trying to cancel
themselves because some of them were
posting anti-asian stuff
there is no rule there's no there's no
rule there's no structure to this
it's literally just a cult man at least
with christianity there's a bible
and people can follow tenets and
understand and read through it
and i certainly believe there are
instances where people selectively you
know will choose to follow
some things but there's literally a
bible you can look at it and yes
it's been retranslated and changed i'm
critical of that but
for now in the united states the king
james bible there you go
you read it you know what it says could
you imagine if one day they were like an
editing board was just came out and
they're like
on page you know 232 we actually changed
this one
you actually can eat shellfish now oh
we're good basically that's what they
did the council of nicea yeah i know for
sure
that's why i'm saying that we twisted
that thing we can be critical of that
but at the very least right now in the
united states and for the past several
generations the bible's been the bible
yep for hundreds of years king james
twisted his own version into reality
but with critical race theories it's not
even written down at the very least they
had to
translate it and argue about it right
yeah i think the
black lives matter had like tenets on
their web page that they
yes they stripped from the webpage and
they no longer have
that was kind of the the bible i mean
that's disrupting the nuclear family
yeah check this out from the daily mail
san francisco school board
strips vice president of her leadership
title and removes her from
all committees over 2016 tweets calling
asians i'm just i'm not going to repeat
i'm not going to say the word
racial disparaging racial term for black
people but she still refuses to resign
so this woman this uh her what is her
name allison is her name allison collins
and anti-asian tweets
oh yes allison collins she posted that
she wanted to have she give asians a
racial awakening
total cult stuff and then she referred
to them in a very racist and disparaging
way
like outright using a racial slur now
they're calling for her to resign
this is all sorts of screwed up for
several reasons for one
this is the vice president of a school
board in san francisco
the people who are indoctrinating your
kids using racial slurs
and then claiming to be anti-racist
that's why that's why i mentioned like
who are these people's parents and
grandparents
homeschool your kids yeah yes i think
that we can't beat them
by insulting them and calling them
horrible for being racist i just feel
like
the only way is to like it's so maybe
it's so obnoxious to say this over and
over again but it's to create a better
system
to be a pinnacle of what you believe in
which i think equality of
opportunity of all of us whatever we
look like i don't really care
um and and then capitalism and roll
around in that
but this is interesting to talk about
too like i almost
completely ignore this stuff in my daily
life i focus on community
communication organization
there is a value to calling out the
problem pros and cons though
if you ignore them right they fester you
have to call it out
the problem is that the left is
working really hard to get to children
younger and younger i mean they're
putting stuff on sesame street they're
getting critical race theory into
elementary schools they're doxing
parents for having wrong think
there's a school i think in north
carolina or south carolina
where they actually did a conference
instructing parents
to go up against i mean to instructing
the teachers to go up against and
contradict the parents
of the the students i mean there's just
all this stuff going on the left is
targeting children with their agenda
and the right is largely like we're
gonna lead by example
and we're going to you know we want to
keep kids out of politics we're going to
take the high road we're not going to
stoop to their level
but we're we're losing because of it and
that's that's a cultural revolution
having the kids indoctrinating them and
then telling them to reject their
parents yeah
hardcore culture revolution i was like
disgusted i
i posted about it for gateway i forget
the name of the reporter he's doing
amazing work on on uh critical race siri
stuff right now that's happening
but he had a whole report about this
this
conference and you read it and it's just
like
we're letting this happen i mean school
board elections don't have party
affiliation listed which i know you
support but i
don't because we're getting all these
leftists who are going into red areas
and they're deliberately going in there
so they can counter what the children
are learning at home from their parents
who are right-wing
i hate it that's crazy but but i think
it's a bigger problem that people have
have given up on their civic
responsibility right so i think yeah you
agree with me on removing party
affiliation big time yeah i was just
studying ancient greece last night i was
telling you i was watching like a
visualization of virtualization of
athens and like they were talking about
the politics and like
they would take 50 500 people from
around
every like of all 50 from all the 10
areas of
attica bring them to greece to athens
and then they would all be part of
politics and then 50 of those 500 would
get chosen
to be like the head of the council this
is everybody every citizen
every i think they were only males at
the time but every citizen male citizen
and they were all involved and they were
all super excited to like adjudicate
lawsuits about like people are they
guilty or they were just so involved
everyone was so involved in the politics
of the day
i think we need that well so so now what
happens is
you get these leftists these marxists
they'll run and be on the school board
and then what people are gonna be like
this person sounds nice and just vote
for them
well the the problem is yes all of this
stuff would be great in a utopia like
where we don't have political parties
ideally i would like there to not be
political parties either
but there are and so when you have
school board elections you don't have
people named
these people are running on things like
we're going to get new school buses
we're going to help build a new football
team
they're not talking about whether or not
they're going to be pushing critical
race theory
and people who live in these red areas
assume that these are people from their
communities
who have you know similar culture and
values
so they're not necessarily digging as
hard as they should be and a lot of
these people are learning it right now
i've seen it happening in quite a few
towns out in west virginia
but it's a problem because people don't
realize i mean they're just like
you know what you know what they say
when you assume yes
yeah it's i can't i kind of feel like oh
i know yeah
we make a butt out of you
i think almost that we should be voting
for smart contracts and not people
because if those people are telling you
we're going to do this this and this and
then they go in and they
also do that and that we didn't vote for
that right
we voted for their contract that's true
yeah interesting that's a good point
actually
politicians should be like these are the
only things i plan to implement and they
should have a very comprehensive package
because that's that's a really really
good point think about andrew yang for
instance one of the reasons i liked him
was that his
policy proposals were off was like nuts
like the dude
sat down and just started writing a book
about all the policies he wanted he had
one on like mma unions and stuff and i'm
like man this guy's what
yeah exactly legit telling you like
here's what i want to do
now i guess the problem is like like you
know you guys both point out
if someone comes to you and says no no
i'm not gonna do all those really bad
things i'm only gonna do the really good
things and then you're like then i vote
for that then i choose you to do those
things then as soon as
soon as they're elected they're like now
i'm gonna do the things you hate and not
the things you like
well we should be able to be like nah
reaches of grievances
you ran on this slate of proposals
you are not implementing them instead
you're bringing in you know critical
race theory
they should be able to be removed
instantly there needs to be a way to do
like an immediate emergency
recall well thanks to covet at least the
one good thing that's come out of this
is that kids
have been learning at home so parents
are seeing what they're getting taught
and they're a lot of them are getting a
rude awakening like real bad
and so i think that that the one good
thing that might come out of this
is that parents are going to be looking
more into the education system
in west virginia i'm sorry i'm a west
virginia fan girl um
yesterday jim justice or it might have
been today um
that was today justice signed a bill um
where now
we're going to be funding students
instead of institutions
so is it like a voucher system or how
does it yeah it's i'm so excited about
this wait
it's literally like a voucher thing
where like you can use it for home
school you
can do private school charters that's a
revolution man it's
so cool i am amped about this this is
something that i've
been talking about for even years even
before i was on the right
but uh yeah it just got signed into law
i think it goes into effect in 90 days
90 of west virginia children are going
to be eligible for it
it's wonderful that means if parents
homeschool their kids
they're going to get a cash stipend for
covering costs and stuff like that yeah
i think they're called hope scholarships
i could be wrong
don't quote me on that but it's
something hope something but they're
gonna do like savings accounts where
you basically can access this money that
is for the child's education
and you can put it towards public school
or private school or whatever you want
teachers unions obviously are outraged
because who the heck wants to send their
kid to public school if there's other
options
uh it's glorious right you know what i
think yay justice
we've we've become a very dull people
and i'm thinking of dull in terms of
like
color saturation we are we're we are all
such npcs
and i don't mean like you or i or you
know lydia or ian specifically
i'm awesome yeah you're great you're the
best just kidding sorry
obviously not us though i do think we're
duller in a sense than the people who
came before us yeah what i mean is that
people have really just given
everything up where are the parents to
be like
i want to go to my school and be
involved and now they don't know that
marxism critical race or whatever you
want to call it is is seeping in well
before my daughter was homeschooled
because
she went to public school for about a
year and a half
i was very involved in the school and i
didn't know half the stuff that they
were teaching because they don't do it
in front of the parents like i went in i
volunteered every friday i
went in as like a teacher's assistant
and i would help with crafts and
cleaning and stuff like that
i went on all the field trips i was
involved in like parents groups
and you don't know any of this stuff i
mean when i was there we actually had a
huge scandal and
the freaking school administration was
threatening to call the cops on all of
us
because the 14 year old student got
raped in the bathroom
by two adult
um illegal immigrants that were wait
what that happened
yeah in rockville the rockville rape now
they say it wasn't rape and that it was
consensual but the fact of the matter is
it was a 19 year old who is in high
school with our our kids
having sex with a 14 year old and
another guy
they took photos of it the whole thing
was horrif
like horrible and so me and a whole
bunch of other parents were upset about
it we started writing being like hey how
many adults are going to school with our
children
and there was nothing about race at all
i mean i was still a leftist back then
who were these guys like why were they
there they were adult illegal immigrants
and they got they're placing them into
the high schools because they're
they're at such a lower learning curve
that they
they're getting placed some of them in
middle schools and so
we all wanted to know how many adults
were going there was nothing about race
there was nothing about immigration we
just wanted to know how many adults were
in the schools they sent a school
district-wide email
saying that racism will not be tolerated
that they'll call the police
it was wild i mean i pulled my daughter
out of school like two weeks later but
i'm so sick of the cult man yeah it's
it's it's so amazing
and the only reason it works is because
people have become
dull when when listen when someone comes
out
and you're like i don't like the fact
that a child was
you know attacked and they go you're
racist shut your
mouth yeah they like swearing almost i
mean they repelled a lot of moms that
day
yeah there was i mean i was in involved
with all these parent groups everybody
was super liberal
but as soon as that email came out we
all started messaging each other being
like what the hell
is this like it was crazy safety
yeah the school's just thinking about
what's the easiest way out
and so they're just throwing spaghetti
at the wall seeing what sticks yeah yeah
i don't know just call them racist
they blocked me on twitter because i
started tweeting about it too the school
district blocked me
nice and i was and i went but that's in
west virginia no that was back when i
lived in
uh just outside dc right it was
rockville the rockville right
there was a ton of coverage of it i mean
i was sending all the emails to
everything
now in west virginia the kid comes to
school and they hand them a gun
there's your gun welcome to school yeah
they used to do that back in the day
didn't they
they they had gun clubs at the schools
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time